so you've been sober for two years what
was the point at which you decided okay
like this is enough my life is on a
downward trajectory and things have got
I had been saying this I had been
talking to myself for a long time you
got to stop this what the [ __ ] you doing
every morning I woke up with a hangover
because I binge I was as a binge drinker
I wasn't drinking by myself I wasn't
drinking in the morning but when I
started drinking it the floodgates
opened and my binge
okay exactly and then it's shots of
Jameson and then yeah right coke and
knowledge could you perform that way or
no no it was always after like at Second
City yeah because when you're doing
second city in Chicago you're like a
local celebrity and you go to the bar
afterwards and everybody just saw you
kick ass for two hours and they're like
we gotta buy this guy shots yeah and
then it's Jameson and then it's [ __ ]
Miller Lite and you know white guy drunk
yeah and then I would get you know I
would be an [ __ ] and you know ya do
stupid [ __ ] right and then ate a burrito
you read a book I write you read a book
so but then that answer question I I
there was one night there was one night
where I took a bunch of mushrooms and
took a bunch of Molly and drank what a
weird combo totally weird combo and so
what it did was the the Molly made me
feel all happy and the mushrooms made me
like look at my life and I had this
[ __ ] up night where I stayed up til
noon the next day my heart and that that
night I was like you're done dude you're
gonna [ __ ] yourself no Eminem's
kids no Eminem's no Molly and mushrooms
that's right yeah they call it candy
flipping or something like that is that
what it is that's a real thing yeah yeah
so you read a book though so then okay
so then the next day I'm talking to
myself you're done you can't [ __ ]
keep doing this and I was calling some
friends and asking about AAA okay I'm
like what you know tell me about this
AAA I have a lot of friends who were
doing it and I was wanted to learn about
it but I always knew and it not to say
anything about AAA but again I'm an
atheist and I know that there was a
religious thing to it whatever whatever
I I know sir people do it differently or
what
and they you know whenever cut to five
years earlier I used to smoke cigs in
college and I read a book called the
easy way to quit smoking okay and that
that is what made me quit cuz it was
great and so then I look and I see this
guy also wrote a book called the easy
way to quit drinking and I read it cover
to cover and I haven't had a drink since
two years ago Wow
you don't have desire I don't know it
takes away the desire discussion often
because he's very I mean and I get it
he's very gung-ho about a a he feels
like that is the only way to get sober
because it works for him right sure but
I'm a believer and you know people Dave
taking different paths based on their
personality based on you know like it's
very circumstantial it's also but we
fight about this all the time and I do
think there are multiple ways to get
sober yes I guess I do
but can I make our gliese please may I
argue in a I've seen bottom-dwellers
dudes that were literally homeless and
been almost on the verge of wet brain in
those specific cases right in in when it
comes to like chronic alcoholism yeah I
believe that 12-step groups are probably
the only way to do it
you know what he is right because I'm
I'm an atheist I don't necessarily
believe in a God but I will say it when
I see someone so [ __ ] out and like
that person needs Jesus because
sometimes that is the only salvation and
there are people who get on the right
path
just when when they when they fixate and
they believe in something so deeply and
even though I don't believe it I think
that it would probably better their
lives also isn't isn't it isn't the god
thing that is truly based upon it is
getting out of yourself and helping
another human being so it's like my
fears and all my depression and
everything is based on self seeking
motives and being self-centered and
living on self will you know where's me
me me
and that's where my depression sits the
reason why people feel better after an a
meeting is because when people are sick
in the room and they have a week or
three days on a day of sobriety and
they're scared and they're they don't
know what to do and you reach your hand
out and go
anyone can i buy your meal do you need a
ride home hey you can call me anytime
you want 24/7 that act of doing that is
what I think the key of a is is helping
another human being the god thing isn't
most people that I know in a ade don't
talk about Jesus it's it's not it's
sexist ambiguous you know thing that
it's just a Power greater than yourself
but I think the real key is is that for
me yeah I might be able to stay so I
mean like I right now I have a I have 14
years but I haven't been too brilliant
and that I'm not active in a in this
last year I would have to say that if I
was more active in a right now I'd be
much happier Wow okay I have a question
then so for someone let's say like me
I'm so my belief is always self
accountability I can never get myself to
think that a higher power took away my
addiction that's suppose I became an
addict that's where that's where I would
find myself a little confused because
what if I was an addict and I'm like
look I don't believe in a higher power
that's going to remove this addiction I
want to believe in myself and my own
accountability to rid myself of your
addiction so how do you how do you
address somebody like but I'm going to
argue this is that you don't have an
addiction so it's like you would know if
you had an addiction that
oh my will isn't working I see if I
don't have a choice it's beyond Nomad
it's beyond me there's nothing I can do
I've I've gone through all these
different roads and all the doors are
shut and I'm [ __ ]
do you get what I'm saying though I've
got to drive the wheel I was then I
wouldn't have need AAA I don't have that
I see okay god I can't understand on my
own it's nine o'clock now I have to do a
show in 30 minutes okay let's wrap up
with a real question take this with you
[Music]